welcome to the Daily I'm Neil Patterson
and on this episode we're going to be
talking about the children who are out
of school more than they're in
it's a phenomenon I'm sure you've come
across already plenty of coverage in the
papers they're known as ghost children
and there were 125
000 of them in the 2022 Autumn term in
England and that is a figure that's more
than doubled since the pandemic you
don't have to be a parent to wonder
about the impact that the months of
homeschooling have had on those children
now add to that statistic this one at
the beginning of the 2022 school year
1.7 million children miss the equivalent
of a morning a week at school that's a
spike of 84 and is the worst set of
attendance figures for the Autumn term
on record
now as I said there has been plenty of
coverage of this phenomenon in the media
but precious little analysis of the root
causes so we sent our people in politics
correspondent Nick Martin to Blackpool
to find out what has been done to get
those kids back into class and what
drove them out in the first place
Nick good to have you on look as
mentioned you went to Blackpool for the
story now the local council's pupil
welfare service has been working with
families with children there who've
dropped off the radar at school tell us
about that work because it is absolutely
fascinating to me it's a very a crucial
part of a community's response to low
attendance and absenteeism and the
people welfare officers have what's
called a statutory power that means
they've got similar powers to social
workers that means they can enforce the
law and remember it's the law Neil to
have children of school age receiving an
education and if parents don't get their
kids to school they're breaking the law
and so these people welfare officers I
have to say in the in the department we
were at uh it's a it's a minute amount
of time but they can enforce the law and
so they have power they work hard I've
seen it up close and their job is to
monitor the attendance of every child in
town and when red flags are raised I.E
they're not in they're going hunt it
down and ask why how busy are they they
are the busiest they've ever been
according to the head of this service
Natasha Armstead who's been in that
office for 23 years she said since the
beginning of term they've carried out 5
000 home visits to parents where there's
a query about whether their kids are
going to school and that of course is
after the pandemic and the pandemic has
had a massive impact on children's
attendance remember schools shut during
the pandemic they were all put onto
homeschooling and I think from what I've
seen over the last few months
hundreds if not thousands well
definitely thousands of children have
struggled to go back to school so where
are we going uh upstairs is this where
you spend most of your time a big chunk
of it yeah
and you also got to speak with one of
the families the units working with in
Blackpool and their 13 year olds Charlie
tell us about them now what was
interesting about Charlie is just the
sheer amount of time that he's missed
school in fact he's only been in school
for about five days in the last two
years he is severely absent and when I
met him he was sitting in his bedroom
doing nothing and we sat down on his bed
and I started asking why he didn't like
school what it was about being at school
that he didn't like the people the
teachers the classes
the uniform
of course I mean a lot of kids would say
that I mean my kids would say that I've
asked them if why they didn't want to go
to school but drill a little deeper and
it was clear that he had quite enjoyed
the isolation education wise of the
pandemic he'd enjoyed homeschooling he
doesn't like being in school there's
something there that stops him from
doing it his dad thinks it's anxiety but
the school and the reports say that he
doesn't have behavioral problems he's
got a good set of friends when he's in
school he works hard he's attaining well
so it was really complicated to try and
understand why he didn't want to go to
school but the fact is he's missed
massive chunks of school and he is one
of hundreds of thousands in the same
boat
so so what are those who are who are
trying to assist at Charlie who are
trying to assist his his dad what are
they actually doing to to get him to
school I mean has he gone to school did
he go when when you were there with them
it seemed to me like there was a huge
amount of what I would call Gentle
persuasion going on so people welfare
going to the home figuring out what are
the reasons what can we do to get him
back at the school the school by all
accounts had done an awful lot they'd
tried to reduce his timetable revise his
timetable to concentrate on subjects
that he likes teach him in isolation but
they had stopped short to agree in what
he wanted which was just to be
homeschooled that is a bit of a sort of
leap into the unknown for authorities if
they started doing that for Charlie
they'd have to start doing that for a
whole host of children so they very much
Hold the Line it really honestly you
should be in school but then it starts
to ramp up and ultimately The Last
Resort is that parents are fined and
they can even spend up to three months
in prison but that is a a last resort
and from the work that I saw in
Blackpool a lot of it is this kind of
negotiation in fact three to five
percent of all their cases end up in
fines but Charlie's case was interesting
and I spoke to his Nan who for me had
been desperately trying to get into
school every morning She lays his uh
uniform out on the bed she you know he
kicks it off she tries to get him out of
bed she even walks in with pots and pans
to wake him up I mean she was at her
Wit's End do you think you and Dad
should be doing more to get him for
school we've dragged him in the car
crying dad's even lifted him out of a
van at one point to put him in the gate
and he just lost his Rag and ended up
punching a wall
but I also spoke to his father James who
wanted him in school but then admitted
to me that he thought that the
curriculum was too rigid that it wasn't
flexing to his son's needs his son he
said wanted to be a pro boxer and a
businessman had a plan a and it felt to
me like James was torn between the need
to get him son into school but kind of
siding with his son's aspirations
bizarrely and it's interesting because I
asked James what his schooling was like
and he'd struggled at school he'd been
bullied he left early without doing his
exams and so it looked to me like you
know history was starting to repeat
itself very similar but he doesn't get
bullied he's got a lot of decent mates
around him as well so I I think he just
knows what he wants to do and he's sick
in touch with her
he knows exactly what he needs to do and
he so far he's doing it he's passionate
boxing just K1 as well he's in the gym
near enough for an hour and a half every
day I wish he was more passionate about
school like that but he knows what he
wants to do and he knows what he needs
and look the assumption is there are
there are so many kids just like Charlie
but Nick give us an idea of the numbers
involved in this we've we've had some
statistics from the government and and
given Devolution I'm assuming that when
we're talking figures here we'll be
specifically referring to England yeah
yeah these are these are England's
figures so apologies for for people in
the other nations the latest figures
from the Department for Education show
that just over 125
000 children were out of school more
than they were in for the first time in
for the first term in the Academic Year
so we've got severely absent Charlie's
severely absent but then other
persistently absent slightly lower down
they missed the equivalent of one
morning a week at school
now in Autumn 2022 1.7 million children
were missing the equivalent of one
morning a week 10 that's incredible that
is absolutely incredible and that's up
84 since the pandemic so if you needed
to understand whether this is a big
issue then you just need to look at the
numbers because this is a huge story
talk us then through the the reasons for
all of this the numbers that you are
talking about it it cannot be reflected
just by persistent truance there must be
some underlying causes some of the big
issues that I've found that are obstacle
to uh to attendance are things like
deprivation the cost of living parents
struggling to hold down jobs and
therefore not monitoring whether their
children are going to school or not and
three times as many children receiving
free School meals are severely absent
from school so we can tell that
socio-economic factors are big here but
by far the biggest cohort of absent
children are those actually with special
educational needs and disabilities
they're more likely than other kids to
miss school in fact four hundred
thousand children who were persistently
absent had some form of special
educational needs so you might have a
vision of the kids hanging around on the
street getting up to no good but
actually this is a critical area for
children who don't seem to be able to
fit into school because they might have
behavioral issues anxiety autism or
other special education educational
needs and for them and their parents
school is a tricky business to get into
and for many they just don't fit in
given the number of children missing who
have special educational needs Sen
can we therefore attribute that in part
to the absolutely polished state of sen
provision and indeed mental health
provision for young people well I think
you can I mean for a lot of special
educational needs pupils they feel like
school is not working for them and
actually School may not be equipped
properly to deal with them and that
comes down to a lot of things but
primarily it comes down to skills in the
classroom and funding now we've during
the course of researching this story
we've met children who have opted out of
school which of course parents can do as
long as they provide a suitable
provision for them homeschooling Etc
we've also seen anecdotally arise in the
number of children opting out of school
and joining virtual lessons by private
providers online with other children
around the world taking exams outside of
the state school system I mean what what
are the schools being saying to you
obviously in Blackpool you have the uh
you have the people welfare service
assisting them but but what are the the
teachers the head teachers saying about
the numbers of children that just simply
aren't turning up for registration in
the morning
this was one of the most surprising
aspects of this story when I started to
sit down with head teachers who are a
pragmatic straight talking Bunch you
know
um they were saying that they they'd
start this on the on the on the sort of
focus of what is good for the child so
they some head teachers said to me some
parents are lazy some parents aren't
smart enough to get themselves to get
their kids to school some parents can't
afford it some parents are having mental
health breakdowns and some parents just
can't physically get them to school
because of distance but what we're
seeing and I've heard this from a few
head teachers now is that in order to
get some children to school head
teachers are jumping in the car in the
morning driving to the kids house
picking him up and bringing them into
school now that's not sustainable head
teachers say they can do that once or
twice a week but that is the extent of
the effort that's going in to try and
get some children into school because if
they don't do that the child is going to
sit at home for all sorts of different
reasons
I want to talk more now about what the
government is doing to bring these
numbers down Nick still with us um do
you get any signal any sign that the
government appreciate the scale of the
problem and that they are working
towards a solution I mean I suppose the
Mantra from Whitehall would be we are
spending more money in real terms on
education than ever before
I think it's fair to say that the
government has placed quite a big
emphasis on this problem I'll be fair on
them for that they recognize that all
the evidence shows that when children
miss school they get worse jesuses and
by all measures do worse in life and
that can impact things like the
aspiration to level up the country and
even you know economic growth and
employment so they see this issue as
being critical the problem is the
numbers are so high post pandemic that
it's going to take a while I think to
bring those numbers down so what are
they doing they've been looking closely
at like tiny little Pilots actually that
have been going on in the country where
they've been trying to figure out a new
way of encouraging children back in to
school and what they announced a couple
of weeks ago is that they're going to
roll out some of those Pilots they're
calling them attendance hubs I'm not
actually quite sure what that means but
they're also saying that there are
mentors available I suspect that's kind
of the stuff that we've been witnessing
in Blackpool let's talk it through how
can we coax you back rather than let's
find you with big magistrates Court
appearances things like that we'll see
whether that starts to bear fruit but as
I say that there is a bit of a mountain
to climb to get back to the pre-pandemic
levels
um the government say that they want to
try and put extra money into this
although they've not really been
specific about the amount but they are
definitely Under Pressure to do it as I
say this is a this is a huge problem and
has huge ramifications for society if we
can't get these hundreds of thousands of
children back into the classroom okay so
let's bring in flick Drummond
conservative MP member of the education
select committee also used to be an
inspector for ofsted so very well
informed on this particular topic flick
good to have you on and I I suppose
there is a very very simple question at
the core of all of this what is the
problem the issue with so many children
not attending school as regularly as
they might
well particularly after covert this is a
this is a massive problem because
children are not in school or being
educated at home because that's the area
that I'm also a concentrating at the
moment they won't have the skills to
take them through the rest of their
lives so we've got about 140 000 ghost
children which are the ones that are
actually on the school role but they
have they've been less in school than
they're out of school and then we've got
about another between 81
000 and 115 000 children who are being
home educated but nobody knows how many
they are and the local authorities don't
know either so the one time most
concerned about are the ones that are
being off-roled in some cases because
the school's not providing what their
they need and maybe their special
educational needs uh something like that
um and or the ones that are well being
well educated but we don't know how well
they're being educated now I'm not
telling parents how to educate their
children absolutely that's not the point
but if they if we put up a register the
local authorities will know who they are
and be able to give that support where
needed or not needed so like you're
planning to table a bill to introduce a
register of children who are being
homeschooled so that at least there's
some some data about how many children
are missing from school rules and
whether or not they're receiving any
education at all why do we lag behind
the rest of Europe in terms of the
quality of the oversight that we have of
our children's education
um I have no idea but we are as you say
an outlier in the whole of Europe we
don't know where all our children are
during the school day I mean it is quite
an extraordinary thought that we don't
know what every child is doing and there
was a safeguarding panel I think in 2020
which had a look and there were 15 cases
of children who weren't on the radar
that were suffering harm three of them
were actually three died and so those
are the children that were letting down
basically if we don't know where they
are what are the resources required by
by presumably by local authorities by
schools
to encourage these children back in and
not just encourage them back in for a
day or two but to keep them coming back
to keep them in education for as long as
possible
I mean the education select Commission
quite a lot of work on this and if you
look at the reasons why children go to
school it's because they find something
that they're interested in I'm very keen
on an extended school day so we can put
more activities more enrichment
activities into the schools so that
where they are working and where
children you know where schools are
providing those sort of clubs and
outside type activities so a combination
of that and I'm also the other area that
I'm personally interested in is looking
at the curriculum as well and how to
make that much more engaging at the
moment we're very exam orientated lots
and lots of assessment and do we need
that or do we need a curriculum which is
going to engage children and make them
ready with all those skills that they
need for the workplace
from your work though in the education
committee you will be aware that school
budgets are stretched at the moment to
put it mildly yeah does does the the
sort of action required to get these
thousands of children tens of thousands
of children back into education does
that not require something of a massive
cash injection from central government
uh it's a combination it does need cash
injection
s can work within
the so for instance a children's
commissioner when she was running
schools in Norfolk she had an extended
school day without any further budget so
schools have to be quite clever on how
they do this but I I agree I mean I
think we are underfunded I'm pushing the
government for more money we do need
more money I mean this is our future
this is our future of our economy
education is probably the most important
thing that we can provide for our
economy so I'm you know very very keen
to you know have chats with a chance to
try and get more more money into schools
I mean we are putting more money than
ever before but it may be that we need
to work out how to use it more
effectively well let's just head back to
Nick Martin for a second before we wrap
up Nick now we have heard about those
quills in motion to identify more
students and stop them slipping through
the cracks But ultimately I mean whose
responsibility is it that children go to
school every day it depends it has to be
it's the parents responsibility you're
right by law morally but you know what
when you go into the homes of a lot of
parents at the moment you can start to
see that there are lots and lots of
complicating factors some parents are
really struggling some parents are
trying to hold down jobs some parents
can hardly pay the bills some parents
are struggling to to keep control of
their children you know these are daily
realities and it's the council's
responsibility in a school's
responsibility to try and Wade through
that and make sure in the interest of
the child the child gets into school so
if you don't spend the money and you
don't support the families and rely on
some parents to do it the children will
be absent from school full stop
now you could argue there is a a broader
debate that could be had in the years to
come about the future of Education
whether that's being educated in school
home or by some other provision whether
that be online
Etc but the fact is for thousands of
children school is still the best place
it provides a safe cons constructive way
of learning and especially for
vulnerable children school is still the
best place but I think there will be a
debate about education and it is
starting to hot up and there are big
questions about what education looks
like in the future
and that is your lot for the daily for
today my thanks of course to Nick Martin
and flick Drummond
this episode was produced by Sydney Pete
with soiler Apparition our editor is
Paul stanworth